the way you have to prevent the fentanyl
crisis is that you actually have to
provide thriving family structures in
religious communities in which people
feel comfortable looking for help but
also can find a wife can have children
are expected to do these things and that
means leaving behind the the things of
childhood and actually taking on an
obligation to live more fulfilled and
better life not just for yourself but
for your community because without that
social Fabric and you taking part in
building that social fabric it doesn't
just fall apart for you it falls apart
for everybody very often in politics we
argue about the things that are at the
top of the iceberg but we very rarely
get to the bottom of the iceberg so the
thing that I would say that the fentanyl
crisis and maybe the Francis you have in
common is that the the thing that has
been dissolving in American life for a
very long time is the fundamental family
structure when the fundamental family
structure dissolves what you end up with
the atomistic individuals atomistic
individuals make bad decisions they tend
to be depressed they tend to be upset
they tend to they tend to be volatile
and so a huge variety of issues in
America are just aspects of this ranging
from school shootings to the fentanyl
crisis to Broken families and higher
crime rates to the transition right all
of these things things are as social
fabric Falls away then sort of the
nakedness of the of the the you know raw
humanity is is left Unleashed and and
you're seeing a lot of aspects of that
so I don't think that they're utterly
unrelated I think that people like to
talk about the transition on both sides
because it's a it's an issue with with
like very very clear demarcated lines
and so that's a fun issue to talk about
because if you're on the right you look
at the show this is just crazy I could
talk about this all day how crazy this
is because it's so crazy and if you're
on the left of God those intolerant
bigots I love calling them bigots this
is my favorite thing is to call them
bigots and so it's a fun issue for
people to talk about fentanyl is is a
less fun issue to talk about for people
not just because it involves Mass death
but also because it actually implicates
some deeper issues that make people very
uncomfortable uh you're actually going
to have to talk about things like is
this happening because of you know as
the right will maintain sometimes trade
and the Outsourcing manufacturing jobs
or is this actually happening because of
the thing that very few people want to
touch maybe across the aisle which is no
one goes to church anymore fewer and
fewer kids are growing up with two
parents in the household there there's
no social fabric there's no social
structure there's no one to keep an eye
on these kids you know what when that
when that happens what that perhaps men
losing the role in society as protectors
and providers for their family actually
unmoors them and makes them depressed
and more likely to get into drug use
right like these are really deep kind of
fundamental philosophic issues and I
think most people tend to shy away from
those because it's not as fun right it's
not it's not as memeable it's not as
kind of tick-tockable and it again it
gets to some really uncomfortable things
about individualism in the age of the
post-enlightenment right I mean like
what I'm talking about is actual things
that create obligations and duties for
people right I'm talking about now like
what you should do with your life I'm
not just talking about what you
shouldn't do or what's stupid I'm
talking about like the things that you
should do in life to make a thriving
society and that comes with actual rules
it comes with things you have to do and
the minute you say to somebody this
comes with obligation people go
right because if you say you know the
way to prevent the fentanyl crisis it's
not just an easy thing about like
bombing cartels the way you have to
prevent the fentanyl crisis is that you
actually have to provide thriving family
structures in religious communities in
which people feel comfortable looking
for help but also can find a wife can
have children are expected to do these
things and that means leaving behind the
the things of childhood and actually
taking on obligation to live more
fulfilled and better life not just for
yourself but for your community because
without that social Fabric and you
taking part in building that social
fabric it doesn't just fall apart for
you it falls apart for everybody people
immediately go wait you want me to do a
thing I I didn't sign up for this I
signed up to listen to a political show
right I signed up to watch CNN I signed
up to watch Fox News I signed up to
watch like you know somebody yell at how
if I just change this politician then
that'll fix the thing this is why I
think there's so much faith in
politicians which is also why everything
is polarized no one should have faith in
politicians politicians are
representatives of the people which
means inherently that if you worship a
politician you're an idol worshiper
you're actually worshiping yourself you
elect the politician then you mold the
goldlink after your specifications and
then you worship it you say why isn't it
doing the thing I wanted to do and if
only I just replaced this golden calf
with that golden calf then that would be
better but perhaps the real work that we
all have to do is not just solved by
going into the voting booth and pulling
the lever on a particular politician
maybe the actual work that we have to do
is the hard work of getting up at three
o'clock in the morning with your kids
enjoying your homework with your kids
and fun and and battling through
whatever hardships you have in your
marriage to maintain your marriage and
then taking care of your parents as they
get older and making sure that the
people in your community if they're
coming on Hard Times actually have
something to fall back on but also
making sure that they're incentivized to
go out and work again like these are
actually the hard everyday things and in
you know my belief is obviously I'm an
orthodox Jew I think in the absence of
religious structure it's very difficult
to promote these things
um but you know those are again
conversations we also believe in fact
Ben and the fact of it is that most
people I are increasingly less religious
in Western Society right so I was going
to ask you this because of course I
understand and by the way we spend time
with religious conservatives you know
and so it's it's wonderful to see the
positive sides of that you know all of
the things you've just talked about and
they are I agree with you 100 those
things are incredibly important for
society to thrive but the fact is you
know we've had different guests on the
show Louise Perry and Mary Harrington
talking about the sexual Revolution and
how that unleashes all of this process
60s onwards but yours I all I'm saying
is I put it to you that your solution
which is right for you and right for
Many religious people in this country is
increasingly less taken up whether you
and I like it or not I agree with you
that it's so what do we do about that
how do we encourage people who are not
religious you know when Peterson had me
on his podcast we talked about a lot of
this how do you instill some of the
values in a society that doesn't believe
in God as much right so I mean I think
Jordan is really great about this which
is the idea that you take on obligations
to do something higher and then you'll
find yourself doing something so do the
thing right in front of you I think
Jordan is really great at this
um you know as an orthodox Junior
proponent of my own religion obviously I
think that my my religion is very
Aristotelian in its approach to life
which is you get up in the morning and
there's a bunch of things you have to do
and if you do those things then you'll
grow increasingly virtuous and you'll
grow increasingly close to God now you
can be Aristotelian not really bring God
into it very much you can say you can
grow increasingly close to Virtue I
think that's stepping one short
logically because then the question is
how do you define virtue where does
virtue come from is there an objective
standard or virtue or is it all just
moral relativism that's why I'm
religious this but if if you don't wish
to go there if you just wish to stop at
that step without going to God or
without going to church or any of that
stuff first of all you're going to have
to find a community of people who agree
with you people who actually want to
build that Community with you maybe
they're not so religious but they have
the same set of values as you do and
then you're going to have to and then
you're going to have to actually
undertake those obligations in a really
methodical and thought out way now the
reason I say that religion provides a
structure is because traditionally that
has been the structure now what's
fascinating is that you can be a
non-religious person living in a society
that values religion and a lot of that
stuff sort of bleeds over to you through
the water through osmosis so here I'll
take the example of Israel what's
fascinating about Israel is that Israel
has a reproduction rate of currently
something like three okay it is the only
Western country that is reproducing
above replacement rates literally the
only one and it's not just reproducing
at the rate of of three there's a huge
disparity between the people who are
religious and the people who are secular
but the so the people who are the most
religious like the haridium the ultra
Orthodox they're having this they think
they're averaging seven kids the the
people who are dancing Lumi which is you
know religious Zionist which is probably
where I would fall if I were living in
Israel that they're having like four to
five kids right I have three I'm having
a fourth that's fairly typical uh and
then the the seculars the seculars are
having three kids why are the seculars
having three kids they're the only
secular people anywhere in the western
world who are having three kids why and
the answer is because the entire culture
values having children when you see
people having kids around you're like
that's cool I would also like to have
kids it seems like that would be amazing
maybe two kids isn't enough my the guy
across the street has eight they seem
amazing like they they they're really
happy and so you see that sort of bleed
down so even if you're not I think that
you can have a society in which you have
Voltaire so long as voltaire's recognize
what Voltaire did which is I don't
believe in God but I sure hope my maid
does right otherwise she'll steal the
silverware
so the the as but I think that as
Western Civilization becomes
increasingly individualistic and
anti-religious it's not just like sort
of apathetic about religion it's it's
become antagonistic toward religion I
think that that bleeds over into a
secular world that was living off sort
of the fumes of a religious Society but
as those fumes dissipate well you end up
with his what do I do this morning how
do I get up what is the moral obligation
what what's in it for me okay so the
religious ideal was always and this is
why again you can do the stoic thing
right there's still philosophers who say
you get up in the morning you do virtue
that's great that may work for for some
people I hope it works for a lot of
people right that I think it's a
valuable belief that's absolutely I
think I take inferences too yeah I mean
I think that there are people who want
to do that I think that's that's great
that's wonderful I think for the vast
majority of people throughout human
history again the thing that orients you
is the idea that when you get up and you
have a duty it's not a duty just because
you think it's good to have the duty
it's a duty because you are enjoying to
do the thing right what makes you so
I'll ask you guys I mean like what makes
you do the thing you don't want to do
right you have an 11 month old baby so
having a lot of kids I I you know it's
it's
it's a pain in the ass right I mean like
having it there they're wonderful as I
always say to people in life when you're
a single dude basically you're you're
sort of spectrum of Happiness to to
sadness is like a 10 to a zero and then
you get married and it goes from like a
20 to a negative 20. because if
something bad happens with your spouse
it's really terrible and then you have
kids and all limits are removed the best
things in your life will be your kids
and the worst things by far in your life
will be your kids it's it's really tough
I mean parenting is not an easy thing so
what motivates you that you know it's
three o'clock in the morning your kid
took a dump and now you have to change
the diaper what makes you get up as
opposed to just turning over and saying
your life you know you deal with it I'm
going back to sleep well for me the duty
is that is an obligation I took upon
myself when we decided to have a child
that's what I signed up to do so why so
why did you do that well what drove what
drove you to make that decision because
that's the question because people
increasingly are not making the decision
to have to get married and then even if
they do get married have kids right
we're an all-time low in terms of people
getting married and having kids I I look
my view is there's a biological
explanation for why we all want to have
kids right so so and actually my wife
and I put it off quite quite late
probably a little bit later than we
would have done I'd love to bang out
five as well at this point uh but anyway
for me uh I I think it's the biological
drive to procreate so the the only
problem with that is that that was true
and it was maintained before the birth
control pill right because the
biological drive to procreate so two
things happen the birth control pill and
the feminist movement so there are two
real drives men had babies because they
couldn't stop having babies and women
had babies because not only could they
not stop having babies they actually
wanted to have babies and they were in
touch with the idea that it is good for
a woman to have a baby now I have entire
movements that teach women that the
highest form of life is don't get
married until you're close to 30 if you
do get married
if it's going to inhibit your career
then you should probably freeze your
eggs and wait until you're maybe 40.
then you have a risky pregnancy at 40 in
which we you know fertilize the egg and
maybe implanted in you and that's like
the apotheosis of civilization and women
by all available polling data are
significantly less happy than they were
your patient's still acquire I said
something completely innocuous about
this on Twitter I've been dealing with
feminists giving me for a week now
so I'm familiar with that I mean but the
bottom line is that how do you reverse
that so they're only in two ways
especially because you can see I mean as
countries get richer and as birth
control becomes more plentiful the the
original pitch for having kids was
twofold one you had a religious
obligation to have kids and two was they
were labor on your farm right those were
the original now kids are at cost it
cost you a lot of money to have a child
it is not an economic not only that you
had kids because when you got old they
were going to take care of you now you
have social welfare not they take care
of you so what's the economic case for
how there's no economic cases it
disappeared it's now reverse economic
case if you want to live high on the hog
you don't have kids you go to vacation
in Rome but you don't have kids and so
that's a real problem but how do you
overcome that and so then it has to be
something like a woman desperately wants
to have kids
and the only way that she is going to
have kids if she makes the rules that a
man has to marry her in order to have
the kids so you have to overcome two
things societally one you have to teach
women it's good to have kids and two you
have to teach women that actually men's
standards for sex are the wrong
standards for sex that if you wish to
have long lasting fulfilling
relationships then hopping in and out of
the sack with people isn't actually a
form of Liberation it's a form of it's a
form of bondage to a certain extent
you're training yourself to how males
tend to think about sex rather than what
is fulfilling for females a biological
function that has existed for literally
all of humankind's existence these are
these are heavy lift it seems to me that
the shortcut on these lifts which is
proved out by literally every
demographic study done in the west is
that if you say God told you to have
kids you have a duty to have kids it is
good to have kids and you're you're
trained in that from the time you're
little like my kids again right now
they're nine by the time they're seven
and and three and in the womb and I
asked my three-year-old daughter how
many kids she wants to have like it's
ingrained in her it's ingrained like my
son I'll ask him how many kids he wants
to he'll say I want to have four kids
right because we're gonna have four kids
like that's the way works I ask you know
like you actually have to bring your
kids up in this way and which is why
across Western Society there are
exceptions who will do the thing you'll
do the thing you'll do like people will
do the thing but that's a lot rarer if
you look at the demographic profiles the
only people the only populations in the
west reproducing it above replacement
rates are in the United States for
example Mormons religious Catholics
religious Jews religious Muslims
religious Protestants that's it no one
else is reproducing it above replacement
rates
so unless those are like the bulk of
your population and then it's sort of
those values sort of bleed over into the
rest of the population which is not the
case in the United States then you know
you're going to have a declining birth
rate and then you're gonna have to do it
through immigration then that's going to
come with whatever attendant problems
Mass immigration comes with right
demographic problems are a real thing so
I I got a question a lot so I obviously
talk about religion a lot and people say
I don't believe in God but I have kids
should I go to church and my answer is
yes you should go to church if you're if
you if you grew up Christian and that's
your religion you should go to church
because you know what that may be the
way that your kid understands the values
the best it's very difficult to make a
sophisticated arguments with
three-year-old it really isn't when
they're 20 and they have questions about
God and they say listen I can't get
there you can say like listen I'll make
an argument for God but maybe you don't
want to maybe that's not your your thing
fine but you know who can't handle that
argument a three year old yeah
and niceness is not a moral value system
foreign